remember that time you and I were
swimming in the ocean
by the way we've talked about this we're
like there are shark fins out there and
the two of us are saying or I I remember
saying it's not it's not a big deal
there's a shark those are those are uh
whatever sharks they're like nothing
sharks yeah yeah they're harmless yeah
they were not they were great summary
come out I'm like oh there's all these
great whites yeah they were great whites
and you and I are just two heads we're
bobbing in the ocean two heads and a
giant shark fin goes by it was
definitely it was maybe eight feet from
both of us
and and both of us I don't know why both
of us are both of us we weren't high or
anything both of us were looking at it
saying uh that's a shark yeah that's
what that is it's a shark yeah and I was
like yeah don't worry about it it's easy
basically it's not interesting that's